[Musique]
48 heures après les révélations de
l'enquète des pandores ap perth des pays
ont commencé à prendre des dispositions
au mexique le président a lancé une
enquête sur les quelques 3000 mexicain
soupçonné de dissimuler des biens dans
des paradis fiscaux en france bercy
vérifie la présence ou non de résidents
fiscaux français parmi les personnes
épinglées bono le maire a promis de tout
mettre en oeuvre pour récupérer les
sommes dues si tel était le cap la liste
des fraudeurs et
on aura la liste des chefs sans faire en
16 ou sur des chantiers des chefs de
gouvernement je sais pas moi la
chanteuse shaqiri c'est la référence
quand on parle aux américains de série
il nous parle du bureau
ils vont boire le bouillon la produire
elle a diffusé une reprise du bureau des
jambes aux états unis c'est l'heure du
sas qui ne devra donc soldes
impressionnantes félicitations sens là
on sent la personne douée non je suis
trouvé une violente empathie viguier bec
violon on a beaucoup de choses en commun
mon mari et moi même si ça soit pas et
on est tous les deux très impétueux on
est tous les deux très
très vivant on n'est pas des gens calmes
internet est devenu le premier lieu de
rencontre des français selon un sondage
ifop sur la digitalisation de la vie
amoureuse conséquence directe du coc
vide un quart des couples se forment
désormais sur des applications c'est
plus que les rencontres dans le cercle
amical ou familial ou bien sur le lieu
de travail à l'eau
attendez j'ai une info que je rentre
numéro vous allez trop vite aux à côtés
c'est fini pour une séparation
malheureusement
[Musique]
plus d'un français sur trois a déjà eu
je cite un rapport sexuel virtuel comme
l'écrit l'ifop concrètement faire
l'amour au téléphone ou via une webcam
avec des pratiques qui se banalise chez
les moins de 35 ans près d'un français
sur deux a déjà envoyé des news et
grands autour du 36 15 la cua ouais
alors version 2 points
mais oui c'est un peu ça mais l'amoureux
téléphone ça existe depuis ya pas
intérêt à ce que est ce que tous les
watts ap et tous les sites
hier soir le monde entier était un ado
qui n'a pas eu de bonnes notes à l'école
privée de whatsapp de facebook et
d'instagram ou plutôt comme les appelle
le ministre délégué chargé des pme alain
griset
ashton drame prise de mou
face de bouc il est fou c'est alain
griset oui certains étaient prêts à
retourner sur les désuets et caramail et
autres msn mais c'est surtout twitter
qui en a profité le réseau fanfaronnait
d'ailleurs en souhaitant la bienvenue à
tous les nouveaux arrivants salut
absolument tout le monde et on n'a même
pas parlé de la quantité sans doute
phénoménal d'argent qui a été perdu avec
les retards engendrés par la crise hier
soir pour les entreprises qui se base
sur facebook sur what's app les échanges
qu'on ne peut pas pu avoir lieu je vous
rappelle que c'est arrivé pendant la
nuit en france mais c'est arrivé dans
d'autres pays qui travaille à cet
instant il ya certainement eu beaucoup
d'argent très dur on n'a pas parlé du
tout pourquoi parce qu'en fait c'est
nous les produits c'est la plus grande
panne que facebook n'a jamais connu elle
aura fait perdre 7 milliards de dollars
en bourse à facebook de cette panne
heureusement les internautes ont gardé
le sourire est la meilleure de solution
c'est peut-être celle de julie celle de
retourner à et mécène voila voila c'est
ce que j'allais dire où elle a viré
on est dans un
jeu
on est dans un monde quand même tous les
jours on se dit ouah ouah ouah ouah ouah
constat aussi vrai que forte c'est ça le
monde est complexe nous on est un peu
binaire on est un peu blanc et noirs
donc c'est pas bien le monde est
complexe
c'est une aventure comme on les aime au
cinéma une actrice est un réalisateur
russe vont quitter la terre pour tourner
le premier film de l'histoire dans
l'espace
après un vol en compagnie d'un
cosmonaute aguerris ils passeront 12
jours dans la station spatiale
internationale
pour y jouer les scènes en apesanteur
c'est un honneur de te donner thomas
pesquet la clé de la station spatiale
internationale qui
c'est au cours d'une cérémonie
symbolique que sa nouvelle mission
prestigieuse lui a été attribuée en
devenant commandant de l'iss s thomas
pesquet devient responsable des six
autres membres avec il séjourne
actuellement trois américains deux
russes un japonais il devient aussi le
premier astronaute français à prendre le
commandement de l'iace lorsque mathieu
va au restaurant oui donc souvent dans
paris des beaux restaurants parce que
mathieu a beaucoup de goût comme on le
sait ouais à la fin quand il a terminé
de manger lee roth edi rama
qu'est-ce qu'il dit aux serveurs ouais
c'est honteux il dit le schéma que de
leurs bombes il dit est-ce que je vous
dois quelque chose
julien courbet l'appareil nous sommes en
direct sur rtl m6 monsieur ghaouti je
voulais juste vous dire que corinne nous
a envoyé ses relevés d'identités bon en
fait ces relevés bancaires il n'ya pas
le virement
monsieur julien courbet en soutenant que
déjà bon show oui bonjour on souhaite
les règles de bienséance en fait non
comme quelqu'un qui veut dire elle
jettera procès où vous avez raison on
nous avait dit à bernard n'aurait pas
apporté je suis bon ben écoutez c'est
pas parce que vous le dites ça veut dire
que forcément que j'ai tort selon vous
sylvain qui vous ment régulièrement les
médias
en général on est manipulé
la sphère médiatique
on sait tous qu'elle est plate cette
foutue planète bleue alors contrairement
à vous j'ai un vrai métier monsieur très
vite et vous laisser ce que j'ai déjà
alors on est aussi un boulanger qui nous
dira il a raccroché voilà c'est monsieur
el ghaouti filles qui faisaient brûler
sa divine mais le coût du restaurant sûr
je te jure à une fois sur trois dans sa
marque sa page du disque matin je dois
quelque chose c'est avoir un petit peu
gêné si merde et or le patron et une
fois sur trois à peu près il revient et
dit non nous sommes très heureux
qui déjeunent pas avec moi c'est
horrible pour moi c'est horrible c'est
mon image et me donne à l'heure et
nourriture moi j'ai toujours bossé j'ai
pas arrêté de bosser je revenais de
berlin ma chaise est arrivé pas ont
commencé à nettoyer l'avion d'accord et
au bout de 45 minutes jeudi poussé quand
même chiant et là une hôtesse me dit
quand on est dans votre état on ne
voyage pas
le dévouement c'est super important
parce que ici je sais que tu fais que te
dé voir moment je fais que me coin d une
fille
ben je fais comme dévoué et eux ces
films c'est un oui mais pas me décevoir
un garçon tu es bête ou quoi qu'est ce
que tu dis un garçon c'est ed voir une
fille dévoué puisque eux et eux eux
s'est massé féminin ans qui suis dévoué
mais avec un et et féminin sont des
briques est ce que tu peux me tirer la
langue dos à dos moi je veux voir
tiens donc
[Musique]
c'est à vous vous avez le mot de la fin
gémeauxla fin qu'est ce que je dois dire
à qui je dois parler à sébastien ou seb
mais c'est bon il me regarde pas la
caméra c'est les téléspectateurs
regardent la télévision c'est top alors
le mot de la fin ça sera asperges